NARRATOR: Novo Selo,
a 12-year-old peasant
girl, Vangeliya,
is playing with her cousins
in a field when she gets
caught up in a freak storm.
She was carried off
into the air by a tornado
and they found her
motionless body in the field.
And strangely, her eyes
were completely caked
with sand and dust.
And she said that
she couldn't open
them without excruciating pain.
And what then began was a
decline in her ability to see.
NARRATOR: After the
accident, Vangeliya
developed a striking ability
to predict the future
and began making
accurate revelations
for the local population.
By the 1980s, Vangeliya, who
adopted the name Baba Vanga,
had given thousands of
accurate predictions
and gained a reputation as the
Nostradamus of the Balkans.
WILLIAM HENRY: Baba
Vanga said that she
could see in her mind's eye.
And when she would
look at a person,
she said that she could
see their whole life
in its totality, complete
from birth through their life
until death as if she
were watching a movie.
JOHN HOGUE: She was a study
of many Bulgarian and Soviet
scientists, who
scientifically started
testing her and interviewing her
and the people that she read.
And they have found that
it is an 80% accuracy.
CAROLINE CORY: Her predictions
were actually very accurate,
which tells us that the
ability to retrieve information
beyond this earth
plane has nothing
to do with our five senses.
In fact, when she
became blind, it
is as if her other
senses developed
to receive messages and
information about the future.
NARRATOR: Among her numerous
claims were predictions
relating to world events.
Many of which would
later come true.
New York City,
September 11, 2001--
BABA VANGA: American president
will fall after being
attacked by the steel birds.
NARRATOR: Two planes hijacked
by members of a terrorist group
called al-Qaeda crash into
the World Trade Center
taking the lives of nearly
3,000 innocent civilians.
Sumatra, Indonesia,
December 26, 2004--
BABA VANGA: A huge wave will
cover a big coast covered
with people and towns,
and everything will
disappear beneath the water.
NARRATOR: A 9.1
magnitude earthquake
off the coast of the island
creates a devastating tsunami,
completely engulfing
over 3,000 miles of land
and claiming the lives
of over 230,000 people.
Washington, DC,
January 20, 2009--
BABA VANGA: The 44th
president of the United States
will be an African-American man.
Everyone will put
their hopes in him.
I, Barack Hussein
Obama, do solemnly swear.
NARRATOR: Barack Obama, an
African-American senator
from Illinois, is sworn into
office as the 44th president
of the United States.
Congratulations,
Mr. President.
JOHN HOGUE: We must remember
these amazing things are coming
from someone who was born
a peasant, who has not read
books, had a slight,
maybe functional literacy
with Braille, but
she has essentially
has no access to televisions,
no access to movies.
This is coming out
of her interiority.
NARRATOR: Baba Vanga proclaimed
her prophetic abilities not
only allowed her to tap into an
unknown realm of information,
but it also put her in contact
with extraterrestrials.
BABA VANGA: Baba
Vanga has talked
about these extraterrestrials
that are invisible or more
like they are presences like
clear reflections of water
shimmering.
And they shared with
her many secrets
which she says are locked
inside the scriptures
of many religions.
We have to wonder
with her where she
was getting this information.
Is it possible she was
able to access some
kind of knowledge
that's out there that
normal people cannot access?